je quitte mon boulot un job super bien
payés au delà de tout ce que vous pouvez
imaginer sa place et dépenser ou la
mollesse ça consiste en quoi le boulon
au travail qu à livrer les mallettes
colombo fruit rond devrait plus jamais
ouvrir la malade
attachez vos ceintures on a déconné
exactement mais en chine
je sois
un poste important
de temps en temps je suis tout comme les
anniversaires sans cadeaux tout ça c'est
fini c'est trop beau bon maintenant tu
vas me dire ce qu'on est vraiment venir
ici je veux faire un petit truc pour le
boulot tous deux s'étaient doutés ou et
la mallette combat remorque à lembach
outre il s'arrête là
pas comme ça que ça marche
c'est nous qui décidons contrat prend
tu peux pas faire ça il ya des règles
faudrait pas que t'arrive quelque chose
un peu tard non
des violences est mal être c'est que ces
titres tu sais pas de quoi ils sont
capables
ferait oublier cette affaire
et comme moi capitaine ferme-la fait le
boulot en brestois